hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar introducing rapid antimicrobial
susceptibility testing by flow cytometry
I'm Christie jewel of laborat and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more please visit thermo Fisher com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by using that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and the
software is continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Tim angles
head of the division of pathology and
Laboratory Medicine at the University of
Western Australia for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. ingles you may now begin your
presentation
thanks Christine I'm Tim Ingles I'm
going to introduce rapid antimicrobial
susceptibility testing by flow cytometry
first up I just want to state any
potential competing interests we have as
you can see a range of different funding
sources including an NGO called lab
without walls our health department here
in Western Australia the University we
have funding from the Gates Foundation
the UK government from NAFTA and Thermo
Fisher Scientific and we do have revenue
and patent sharing agreements in place
now this webinar is going to cover the
topic of testing for antimicrobial
susceptibility and by obviously
inference antimicrobial resistance you
can see from the outline here that we're
going to have a look at where we are now
where we need to be and how we're going
to get there so first up let's have a
look at the wicked problem of
antimicrobial resistance most of the
professional population involved in
clinical microbiology and infectious
diseases and many many healthcare
workers and a good deal of the
well-connected population realize that
we've got a global problem with
antibiotic resistance
Health Organisation has highlighted the
global loss of the efficacy of
antibiotics and this crosses the entire
one health spectrum from human to
veterinary to environmental health part
of this has been because of the ease of
transmission of antimicrobial resistance
genes but there are clearly other
factors including the transmission of
microbes bearing resistance in the first
place this has been referred to as the
double transmission paradigm
result of this there's an escalating
prevalence of untreatable infections
which has become such a global problem
that it's impacting on the efficacy of
treatment in every single nation state
that is tracking the issue and what
we're all finding is that there's a
delayed time to effective treatment and
this increases the risks of complication
and in serious infection the risk of
death from infection now in the
laboratory the detection methods that we
use are becoming increasingly
technically demanding so the burden on
the entire healthcare system but
specifically on the clinical laboratory
is becoming more and more difficult to
bear now I've summarized this in this
slide where I shown you the wicked
problem or in the old money vicious
circle and if we start at the top left
with the most obvious impact of
antimicrobial resistance which is the
reduced efficacy of antibiotic treatment
now this leads to top right delayed
benefits from the use of antibiotics so
if there's going to be any benefit at
all it takes longer for them to kick
into action that produces a diagnostic
challenge to the clinician managing the
patient and the clinical laboratory
running tests a man in turn results in
broader spectrum antibiotics given for a
longer period of time and more commonly
ineffective antibiotic treatment which
results in increased resistance and that
further compounds the problem of reduced
antimicrobial efficacy so you can see
how this is a cycle that feeds itself
and is part of the reason why we have
escalating problems of antibiotic
resistant
there are a range of proposed solutions
and in the UK government's report led by
Jim O'Neill an economist who took a very
serious look into the issue back in 2015
he reported back that there were 10
major initiatives that needed to be
introduced and at least four of those
concern the clinical laboratory because
the laboratory is the source of
evidence-based antibiotic use and good
antimicrobial stewardship they use the
correct use of antimicrobial agents that
preserves and conserves the dwindling
stock of effective antibiotics that we
still have left obviously there is a
need to keep close watch on
antimicrobial resistance with good
standardized surveillance systems and
the laboratory is also a key to
discovering new antimicrobial agents so
big is the problem that this came to the
attention of the United Nations General
Assembly and are back in 2018 this was
officially described as a high-level
threat to global health and now regarded
by the World Health Organization as one
of the leading threats the health of the
world's population so now the w-h-o
requires national antimicrobial
resistance plans
wh o--'s recognition centers on for us
improve laboratory Diagnostics and if
you drill down into the details of what
they recommend they recognize that there
is a need for improved accuracy but
importantly at speed because the
combination of speed and accuracy
mounted microbial susceptibility testing
can and should feed up antimicrobial
treatment decisions but they really need
to go a lot faster than our current
suite of antimicrobial susceptibility
tests if they're going to impact initial
treatment of severe infections though
aho also recognizes that the faster and
more accurate antimicrobial
susceptibility tests that they envisage
would improve detection of antimicrobial
resistance would sharpen surveillance
and improve new antimicrobial drug
discovery
but clearly we've got a bit of a
shortfall with our antimicrobial
susceptibility tests currently they are
too slow to affect those initial
treatment decisions by the attending
physician they don't have the accuracy
to deal with borderline susceptibility
results at given drug bug combinations
and in critical infections patients in
the critical care unit or the emergency
room they can be unreliable in
predicting which antibiotics should be
used and how they should be given so
these susceptibility tests unfortunately
are also not necessarily validated for
emerging or unusual infections and
antimicrobial resistance phenotypes
compounding all of this is that the
different susceptibility testing methods
we currently use can quite often throw
up discrepancies but further delay the
time to a clinical laboratory issuing a
susceptibility test report all of this
contributes to that machine that is
generating further antimicrobial
resistance now let's move on to
solutions because we could go on
describing the problem we've got for the
rest of the webinar but without coming
up with any answers to the problem the
approach that we've been taking is flow
cytometer assisted antimicrobial
susceptibility of that what fast we
short the method that we use analyzes
the uptake of fluorescent dyes that bind
to bacteria and give us an opportunity
to measure very accurately the effect of
any microbial agent exposure
our method has been compared directly
with broth micro dilution using the
standard teeter method according to
manufacturer's instructions as a result
of this we've come up with a series of
short faults described some of the key
aspects of the method and I just want to
touch on these briefly the AUP is the
antimicrobial unexposed population that
if you like is your negative control the
CDE is the concentration dependent
effect that enables you to determine at
the m.i.c equivalent and the PC although
we've recently renamed this 4p IC is the
predicted effective or the predictive
inhibitory concentration and that is our
approximation to the m IC and exactly
how this maps out you'll see very
shortly how we achieve this result is
surprisingly simple if you've got the
right equipment we take a standardized
suspension starting on the top left of
this slide of the bacteria in question
we put them into Muller Hinton broth as
you would expect for susceptibility
testing we then automatically dispense
these using Auto inoculated device into
a 96-well tray pre-inoculated with
antimicrobial suspensions and obviously
we are using the censored heater mi c
standard trays these then go into the
autosampler for the attune NXT acoustic
flows automata and then we get our
results out of the flow cytometer after
a period of between half an hour and
just over three hours depending on the
amount of incubation that's required for
the drip they given a drug bug
combination
you'll see at the bottom right that in
this version of the fastest a we've used
an auto inoculated device to help
standardize the inoculation of the
96-well sensitive tray and this is part
of the reason why we can get really good
reproducible results why fast works is
really based on our calibration against
the current internationally recognised
standard method the broth micro dilution
and the sensitivity version that we have
been using uses exactly the same
sensitivity trays as we use fast for
conventional broth micro dilution the
differences the standard test takes 18
to 24 hours whereas obviously fast takes
around three to four hours to complete
before m.i.c determination but it also
works because we have amazingly
consistent effects for a specified drug
bug combination we can get the same
results time after time after time
provided we follow the standard
operating procedure that we have setup
from salt and the other key feature that
the opportun NXT allows us to do is to
internally control every single assay
that
AUP the anti microbial unexposed
population is determined each time a 96
volt ray goes through the system
now here are the sorts of pictures you
can generate with proprietary
third-party software and this gives you
some contour diagram starting top left
there you see a contour diagram on a
flow cytometer data output simple
bivariate plot of forward scatter versus
the dye channel that were picking up on
which happens to be at the blue one
channel for the blue laser and its first
filter and here we're looking at the dye
site o.9 you can see a nicely tight
grouped AUP that contour is then
overlaid after analysis of different
antibiotics in different wells of that
96-well plate and we've given you four
different drug bag combinations with
four different classes of antimicrobials
along the bottom row and going from the
left where we've gotten a minor
glycoside amikacin next to Kalista and
yes we can do coalesced in with this
method very neatly then onto
ciprofloxacin and finally onto meropenem
you can see that there are different
patterns of susceptibility with the
different antimicrobial agent classes so
you you will find that these patterns
are highly reproducible at the point of
susceptibility but the susceptibility
threshold that signature for
susceptibility will be generated at
different concentrations of
antimicrobial according to where the p
IC or mi c sits and you can see what is
happening at each of these the general
principle is that there has been a shift
in the bulk of the measured population
as a result of antimicrobial exposure
outside of that zone that corresponds to
the AUP
moving on to the bioinformatics we've
obviously been very teamed to handle the
data that comes out of the attune NXT as
quickly as we can because when we first
started doing this it became clear to us
that we were going to generate enormous
quantities of data from a 96-well plate
the tune analyzes on many different
dimensions and as a result this is
complex big data for a 96-well plate and
therefore we have been working with some
data scientists in order to generate a
better analytical pipeline and we have
done so using a machine learning process
this can be rapidly applied to flow
cytometry data output this calculates
the AUP
at the CDE and the P IC and that enables
us to achieve a same-day
analysis from direct analysis of
clinical cultures this is the overall
workflow for our machine learning
algorithm which was published in Journal
of medical microbiology and towards the
end of last year and you can see that in
broad terms we format the data from the
attune we then clean and present the
data through to a data selection gate we
then go into a classification and
visualization process that generates a
robust approximation to the m.i.c
the accuracy we've achieved is very
close to that of a conventional broth
micro dilution mi see even though we're
doing so in a three - just under five
hour period it takes overall about five
minutes of liquid handling for the
operator we've got very consistent
endpoint determination and we've been
able to apply this directly to sterile
fluid specimens such as blood cultures
and peritoneal dialysis fluid just to
give you one example that was presented
at last year's antimicrobials meeting in
Sydney Australia you can see a selection
of commonly used intravenous
antimicrobials we've got a good
categoric agreement with the
conventional susceptibility testing
particularly for meropenem and whether
we use you cast or clsi thresholds the
interpreted thresholds give us a
generally very high quality output the
mean reduction to AST results with
manual fluid handling this is before we
were even using an auto inoculator was
thirty one point two hours faster than
the clinical laboratory was producing
these results by a variety of
conventional culture dependent methods
but importantly a card based proprietary
reading system used to generate M ICS
was what was compared here under the 14
discrepancy the single commonest reason
for discrepancies between the broad
micro dilution and our fast results was
the fact that that card reader was
giving our errant results and when we
use the sensitive lights and did a
retrospective direct head-to-head
comparison we found that the majority of
those discrepancies disappeared and
there were no very major errors
now I've provided you with some links to
open source information and I encourage
you to have a look at these different
publications for your own information
I'd just like to draw to a conclusion
the fact that we are now able using cast
provide an unprecedented combination of
percent ability to have speed and
accuracy we can do it with off-the-shelf
technology in its current form as a
research use only approach so if you
want to develop a laboratory developed
tests and valid verify it within your
own clinical laboratory environment
off-the-shelf technology is available to
do that now you can pair this method
with sterile fluid culture specimens and
achieve a same-day susceptibility result
and we've done that as a proof of
concept so if you take this automated
version of the ast workflow a wide
antimicrobial test repertoire that we've
developed and dedicated interpreters
software you're going to be able to
improve your the feasibility of truly
rapid antimicrobial susceptibility
testing in your own lab I just like to
before I sign off credit my colleagues
in the research and development group
here at the University of Western
Australia and importantly our colleagues
in the clinical laboratories here on the
qe2 campus of path West laboratory
medicine and before I hand over to to
Christie I think we're in a position to
take some questions
so Chrissie over to you oh and I should
perhaps just mention for those people
who want to meet up with members of the
team and not just me will be both
antimicrobials 2020 in Melbourne this
month from the 20s
to the 29th and will be Ahmed where
we'll be presenting a machine-learning
for clinical microbiology workshop the
day before Ahmed begins thank you and
thank you dr. ingles for your
informative presentation as you
mentioned we will start the live Q&A
portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have a question you
would like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay let's get started
dr. angles we've got lots of questions
already coming in let's start with this
one
why is an a tuned NXT flow cytometry
needed for the fast method that's become
very clear to us over the last year or
so of our internal verification process
the tuned NXT is a very accurate
acoustic enhanced flow cytometer with
optimal performance in our hands within
the dynamic range that's dictated by
bacterial size so it really is a case of
best platform for the task that we've
set it
thank you our next question what
bacteria can be tested by the fast
method so far every bacterial species
that we have tried has been converted
into a successful fast si we the latest
account had 67 different bacterial
species that we've tried and you
wouldn't be surprised to know that all
of the organisms that are at the top of
the CDC and for that matter the World
Health Organization's hit list as
priority organisms we have analyzed
we've included amongst that most of the
highly clinically important new bacteria
obviously the antibacterial ease were
we're a starting point for us but a
hospital important gram negative
organisms a gram positive organisms and
importantly we found that yeasts have
been very easy to run as well so it
really is just down to the amount of
time necessary to do the verification
and validation work that dictates how
while you can go
now dr. Engels foot fastidious bacteria
can be tested
I guess that's a natural follow-on from
the last question we have a problem in
Australia that other parts of the world
we're starting to see with
multi-resistant gonna cocci and so we
were really keen to deal with this
organism for which with some
antimicrobials there isn't even a
standard brought micro dilution method
so we've been able to do now serious
species both Neisseria gonorrhea and
meningitis where the W strain has we've
seen a little bit of penicillin
resistance in that and so we're very
keen to be able to do that and for those
people concerned we've we published in
gates hope and research a our experience
with occupational health and safety
assessments that soon attune use because
we wanted to do that before we went
ahead with handling meningococcal in an
acoustic speedometer we've we've dealt
with difficult to handle organisms like
streptococcus Moni I him off litter
influenza I was very easy and and the
list goes on
we've got other fastidious organisms
that we've yet to work through and we're
going through a methodical hit list that
will include amongst other organisms
anaerobic bacteria but we've yet to
present any data on that
thank you dr. Engels now this question
has come in a few times can the fast
method be used directly on body fluids
such as blood
yes that's that's a really good question
that we wanted to address as a priority
very early on and the answer is
emphatically yes we presented our
preliminary data at antimicrobials 2019
so almost a year ago and I've alluded to
that in this webinar we have
subsequently conducted a prospective
preclinical analysis of blood cultures
handled very rapidly with the automated
method and without without spoiling our
own Thunder with the presentations that
are going to be made later on this year
I can advise you that the results are
comparable with direct analysis of
organisms that have been grown either in
broth or have been taken from plates so
we're getting comparative at comparable
accuracy directly from blood culture
fluid with a very simple liquid handling
step
now dr. Engels I know you mentioned what
bacteria can be tested by the South's
method can you tell us what antibiotics
can be tested by fast oh yes good
question we've we've worked her way
through 30 or more different antibiotics
and the multiple combinations
we've tried have all ultimately yielded
to our analysis you would not be too
surprised to know that the beta lactam
agents penicillins the catalyst for ins
the carbapenems
and the pennons have all been dealt with
very quickly and very efficiently there
are one or two that proved a little bit
challenging with some of the multi
drug-resistant phenotypes but we have
methods for all of those now our amino
glycosides you've you've seen a
different approach to the data analysis
was needed with those but that has been
resolved the quinolones were very easy
the obvious difficulty we anticipated
with bacteriostatic agents but we have
found that we can use the same overall
method for all of the different drug bug
combinations that we've used certainly
all of those that are present in
standard sensitive plates for
gram-negative bacilli for grand
political cocci plus those that are used
by you cast laboratories with their
simple one plate we found all of those
antibiotics can give us accurate MSE
equivalents or p IC so this is very very
wide range of antibiotics
dr. Engels now who are the most likely
users obsessed at this age clearly when
we're talking about either those early
adopters who are interested in research
use only applications so bigger centers
teaching hospitals big clinical research
centers that have got a sustained
interest in antimicrobial resistance and
there's a lot of those around the world
and clearly we've we're working with a
number of those sites not just in our
region but increasingly with people
overseas as collaborators and that
confirms the view that the early
adopters are going to want technology
that can give them the accuracy it can
give them the speed that fast allows but
also allows them to produce a phenotypic
susceptibility signature that might that
could be aligned with any genotype
analysis they're doing of emerging
antimicrobial resistance patterns both
laboratories that are equipped to be
able to verify their own tests are
probably going to be the fastest are
into this space but we are in the
process of setting up standard operating
procedures for adoption of the method in
those laboratories that want to to get
on with implementing this as quickly as
possible that process clearly has taken
us quite a long time largely because of
the regulatory considerations that we're
working towards and we'd really like to
be able to pass on the benefits that
that very detailed and protracted work
has has achieved without everybody
having to repeat all the work that we've
done to get here so big centers centers
particularly facing multi-drug
resistance problems and
something I would emphasize is that the
research use only approach is one that
is actually taken with quite a lot of
our second and third tier antimicrobial
susceptibility test methods that are
used selectively after the initial rapid
standard screening tests have been
completed
thank you dr. ingles now we've
identified the users could you explain
how much training is needed to perform
this fast testing sure this is probably
a logical follow-on from my last answer
bearing in mind that it took house a
long time of tinkering with and then
fine-tuning
sorry no pun intended the workflow
involving the YouTube and X teams that
steep learning curve is something that
others do not need to repeat
particularly if they have access to
experience flow cytometry
we found with our partner institutions
that those centers that have got people
with flow cytometry experience working
in clinical microbiology labs this is a
much faster lead time and obviously if
you have an SOP to work too then it is a
matter of implementing things it's
clearly not an overnight task and we
anticipate that the longest time getting
set up will actually be getting your
calibration process aligned with
whatever definitive quantitative
susceptibility test method you've got in
place like broth micro dilution m.i.c
that's what drives a slow implementation
time so a laboratory that has got flow
cytometry possibly people who've moved
out of psychology which is going more to
molecular methods these days and into
clinical microbiology or alternatively
people who've got a good handle on
molecular methods and understand the
complexities of sophisticated new
laboratory equipment but importantly
centers that have got an existing broth
micro dilution technique up and running
those will be the centers that find that
this is is quickest to set up and one
thing I'd like to emphasize those are
very keen to help people who want to get
into this technology do so we will be
assisting vir our contacts at thermo
with providing standard operating
procedures in the near future of
published methods so however long it
might take you to achieve that first
base if we can do anything to help you
get to that first base quicker and with
less of the usual internal laboratory
quality control processes than you
thought might be necessary well then
let's go for it let's work together
thank you this fast work with the you
Cal store clsi interpretive breakpoint
that was a question that we needed to
address at the beginning of last year
and we have found consistently that as
long as the right dilutions are present
on this sensitive plate you can generate
data that can be interpreted by both
methods and the the in-house data mining
software that we have developed allows
us to switch from new cars to clsi and
back using the same interpretive points
so if you're one of those clinical
laboratories like the one that I work in
that at the moment use of both clsi and
you Carson interpreted data the ability
to switch backwards and forwards is is
actually important but most folks in the
clinical microbiology world are one or
the other and yes we can emphatically
say that the principle of the tests
works for both the interpretive criteria
can be applied to a set of data
generated out of a sensitive tree but
exactly how accurate the results are
will depend on whether the one or other
interpretive standards ideal break
points are represented on the tray that
you've got going through the machine
thank you dr. ingles now we have time
for a few more questions but I do want
to remind our audience that those
questions we are not able to answer
today and those that are submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by dr. Engels via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration ok dr. Engels looks good in
a few more before we finish what does
work with fast we've we've taken a look
at a series of dyes and most of them are
they're obviously all fluorescent dyes
but most of them are taken up clearly
during bacterial metabolism and growth
and division they can illustrate
different aspects of bacterial function
but the one that has worked most
consistently across all of the drug bug
combinations that we've been testing is
cytonemes clearly one of the dyes in the
molecular probes vicarage and sable it's
been around for a while people have used
it for a number of things we have found
this works very nicely indeed and so
while there are other dyes we could use
we do find that the simplicity of our
site o.9 method and it's broad
applicability is a very strong argument
for concentrating on that one for the
meantime dr. Engels is there any use for
a microscope in the fast lab yes and
this came as a bit of a surprise to us
because we thought that bacterial flora
cytometry is a really cool thing to be
doing you shouldn't need a microscope to
produce your results and in a sense some
people might have it right when they say
that but the reality is that clinical
microbiologists are not used to looking
at flow cytometry data on screen and if
you manage to persuade a psychologist
who's got experience or flow cytometry
to step into the clinical microbiology
lab they're often not used to looking at
bacteria under microscopes so what we
did was we got a digital UV microscope
into the lab where we did our initial
development work and we found it was a
really useful tool for helping
communications between our flow
cytometry and our bacterial
physiologists it's particularly handy
when clinical microbiologist such as
myself step into the development
laboratory because we can bring the
narrative together showing changes in
bacterial shape and size and features
sometimes within the cell visible under
the microscope and correlate those with
what we're seeing on the screen of the
flow cytometer now with time your
bacterial flow cytometry
get to the point where they can see
those patterns that you've seen already
in the slide pack that are suggestive of
particular mechanisms of antimicrobial
action and you can see the thresholds
occurring in real time and that's very
exciting for a clinical microbiologist
to know that we can do things that
quickly but the microscope does help and
in the development phase it gives you an
opportunity to do some some internal
validation work a reality check if you
like on what you're seeing with a flow
cytometer if you're not used to flow
cytometry data or if you are a flow
cytometry to understand what is
happening in real time to bacterial
physiology so we see it as a natural
pairing of the development workflow but
once you get into producing
high-throughput fast based and in
microbial susceptibility results you're
probably going to put the microscope to
one side and concentrate on high
throughput flow cytometry with an auto
sampling device
thank you dr. ingles I think we can fit
in two more what ancillary equipment is
needed above the tune and XT sure I just
touched briefly on the importance of the
auto inoculator that reduces the amount
of manual fluid handling
there are obviously occupational health
and safety issues surrounding that for a
clinical laboratory with a high
throughput but it also improves the
reproducibility of liquid handling so
we've found that that has been a great
way to improve the quality of our
results so that's a one item that should
be regarded as part of the fast package
we'd also strongly recommend the use of
the auto inoculated because that again
will achieve greater consistency in an
occupation of your BMD 96-well trays and
in particular if you are doing
verification validation work where
you're running a sensitive to DMD panel
both by conventional overnight
incubation and running it using the fast
technology then you're going to want
that degree of reproducibility where the
auto inoculator
so not the auto sampler that sits with
the NXT but the aim instrument provides
that deliberate if you're already using
the sensitive vision system then you're
probably using it an aim device already
and that's that's something to bear in
mind if you want to speed up sensitive
MI sees think of the attune NXT with
auto sampler as a way of achieving a
mark to sensitive rock micro dilution
thank you dr. ingles and i victor up
with this question as it's come in a few
times as well are there other
applications of the fast method yes for
sure
once you've calibrated a representative
set of organisms with a given name and
we've started with Klebsiella pneumoniae
because of its it's multi-drug
resistance patterns within this region
and some previous work we did on on the
epidemiology of multi-drug resistance
once you've got that reference panel
that's been carefully characterized
against a given antimicrobial let's just
say a carbapenems such as meropenem then
you've got a means of screening new
potential carbapenems for their youth
against the organism panel that you've
got so you can actually use it for drug
discovery you can for some of those
really difficult mechanisms of
multi-drug resistance that involve
things like bacterial efflux pumps as
well as antimicrobial in activating
enzymes for those complex mechanisms
that can be really difficult to properly
formally determine susceptibility by
genomic means you can usefully do an
accurate phenotypic analysis of where
that m.i.c actually lands for that
particular organism and so those
bacteria that have got em ICS that sit
in or around the breakpoint we believe
that what we're achieving by doing fast
is creating an environment which we can
more rapidly but probably in a way
that's a bit more representative of of
bacterial physiology test those
borderline mechanisms and we hope and
we'll we'll know this in the fullness of
time
detect
subtler forms of antimicrobial
resistance that are emerging within our
region you may know and certainly those
people do a lot of antimicrobial
resistance tracking monitoring and
surveillance we'll know that the early
stages of the emergence of a new
mechanism of resistance often occurs
with very subtle rises in the mi see
below the established and
internationally agreed break point so
this degree of accuracy is we believe
going to be very important in future
surveillance a further approach having
mentioned genomic methods of analyzing
multi drug users is to team up fast
method technology with genomic
technology and achieve a much more
comprehensive appreciation of emerging
mechanisms of antimicrobial resistance
so in a nutshell we believe that fast
gives us a toolkit for looking at
antimicrobial susceptibility both from a
patient by patient clinical point of
view from a an antimicrobial resistance
the valence point of view from a
mechanistic systems biology perspective
and finally from a screening new
antimicrobial agent candidates
perspectives so a really useful tool kit
that has applications spread all the way
from clinical microbiology laboratories
to to Big Pharma
thank you dr. ingles now how many final
comments you would like to leave our
audiences well I guess just to wrap up a
couple of things I've mentioned we'd be
very keen to work with centers that are
looking seriously at installing fast
technology help them with SOPs that will
make it easier for them to to cast the
first few pebbles in the pond and make
some ripples so that'd be good
secondly do have a look at the
publications that we've got out there
that describe the method there's going
to be a number coming up in the in
linear near-term but have a look at what
we published in like German micro
towards the end of last year have a look
at that our first description of our
method in scientific reports back in
2017 and then finally for those
attending antimicrobials 2020 in
Melbourne or Ahmed in Paris in April we
look forward to touching base with you
there and possibly welcoming you to our
workshop the day before exercise thank
you
and thank you dr. ingles for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I would like to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions as a
reminder those questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by dr. Engels via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand
and Mavericks will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day